il est rémois léger une nouvelle vient
de l'apprendre c'est incroyable c'est
sur télé loisirs.fr oui il ya l'admirent
poutine qui va chez hanouna la semaine
prochaine face à bah ouais ça va
s'arrêter face à bla bla ils veulent
changer la saveur kad merad ou non
poutine mais il n'aime pas se montrer
mais en revanche il est montré ses
muscles
ah oui ça oui il à hellemmes il s'est
levé si elle vient vous comprenez il
vient dans l'émission chez vous il sera
sorti de bordeaux abbas et hugo manos
démocrate l'a aidé à tenir et or vous
savez l'autre jour j'étais à new york
j'ai vu dans le club gay un énorme
poster de poutine ne vous savez tornio
[Musique]
92% des français se déclarent intéressés
par cette guerre entre la russie et
l'ukraine leur attention est d'autant
plus forte qu'ils ressentent de la
tristesse de la peur face à une
situation qui le révoque l'horreur il
manifeste de l' empathie à l'égard des
ukrainiens 94% des français s'en sentent
solidaires et sont même 79% à vouloir
accueillir des réfugiés
alors déjà on le dit malade malade est
ce que l'on parle du malade et
psychologiques ou est ce que c'est une
maladie physique comme un cancer ou
quelque chose comme ça on rappelle qu'il
a 70 ans
vous savez il faudra compter toujours
celle à des maladies psychologiques gelé
30 dingo oui parce que s'achèveront de
mon livre
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
to
you make a
accueilli par un expression a compris qu
aucune de jouer en ligne mieux vaut donc
se défouler dehors car c'est beaucoup
plus sympa surtout avec ça j'ai une
autre passion qui est assez récente
c'est le laser game
donc ça peut aussi des verts purement
culturel et les lasers et comme un
escape game et avec des lasers
ont permis des saunas
alors
[Applaudissements]
nicolas sarkozy très sûr de lui commence
à dire avec moi on va parler des sujets
qui fâchent et il n'y aura aucun sujet
tabou les centaines de morts en
tchétchénie pour moi c'est inadmissible
anja politovskaïa de la journaliste
russe assassinée pour moi c'est
inadmissible
vladimir poutine écoute et lui demande
c'est bon t'as fini là
j'ai
tu vois ton pays il est comme ça
mon pays il est comme ça
là maintenant de deux choses l'une ou
bien tu continues sur ce ton et je
t'écrase
ou alors tu arrêtes de parler comme ça
et tu verras je peux faire de toi le roi
des rats vous savez c'est un mec qui
sait tous les jours deux heures de sport
chaque matin jours après une demi heure
avec une copine après en bouillon je
vais vous donner la recette pour
renforcer la vigueur la station solo
tivo rota l'une des plus profondes de la
ville 95 mètres sous terre est conçu
comme un refuge anti bombardements
ils sont 250 ce soir là
tellement épuisé que ce papa s'est
endormi en écrivant un texto ont demandé
à houellebecq qu'est ce que vous pensez
du monde d'après le kof valide il a
répondu ce sera la même chose en pire
pour la première fois les meilleurs
effets visuels
[Musique]
ah oui c'était beau vous effets visuels
aussi bonjour mademoiselle en sarre soir
voici mon cul oui ou non le voir briller
hommage à la q
la première chose dans une relation pour
être intéressant pour pour se rendre
sympathique ça ne pas parler de soi en
réalité quand vous parlez de vous tout
le monde s'en fout complètement et donc
le jeu pour pour se rendre sympathique
je me présente c'est compliqué justement
il faut essayer de se présenter au
travers du prisme de l'autre essayait de
comprendre qui est la personne qui est
en face c'était ma petite déclaration
d'amour à moi
aussi des mains
et surtout
à louis garrel que j'aime
louis oui complètement à la parole la
parole pour que c'est la situation la
plus marquante que j'ai jamais vue de ma
vie je répète ma question est ce que
vous comment on peut expliquer la face
ne sommes pas je suis pas dans la tête
des stones ce n'est forcément plus
fatales vous êtes comme quoi vais je
comprends pas du tout nous demander de
dire ce que pense martin scorsese c'est
pas possible
nancy je suis philippe la neuve c'est
pas mon défi vous devez vous donner les
fiches de scorsese est ce que vous
écoutez mes réponses
oui
merci beaucoup
il applique
pouvez vous remercie et tais toi
maintenant des toits dans le film mean
streets 1973 l'artois scorsese a mis des
chansons des stocks il a pas mis des
chansons des beatles
écoutez les sea dogs bon quand on pose
une question est ce que c'est une
tendance du retour un peu des disques
compacts et les papys du rock qu'est ce
que ça vous l'observez bon je raccroche
mère-grand c'est comme ça que j'appelle
ma mère mais un grand jeu c'est que à
cette heure là tu dors je sais aussi tu
ne regarde quasiment jamais la
télévision
sauf parfois l'après-midi une émission
de vente aux enchères animée par sophie
davant qui s'appelle affaires conclues
dans laquelle j'ai peu de chances de
passer pour un revendre cet objet
dont la brenaz j'espère
signer dès lors son label match trop bas
comme c'est merveilleux comme
l'efficacité tremayne art par l'odeur
alléché tapas presque gajan et jambon
sous l'angle du beau corps c'est joe que
vous me blessant l'open sentir mans
c'est votre match tu rapportes à votre
marche plus c'est le mix fait des taux
de ces labels je voudrais vous dire que
ce jour aujourd'hui jeudi je me souviens
au québec mais moi je m'en souviendrai
toute ma vie et j'espère que j'aurais
autant de chance avec mon prochain film
sur l'histoire de martine aubry merci
beaucoup
je rêve une société dans laquelle on
n'est pas du tout voilà une société
qui ferait attention à nos enfants
à nos santés à notre nature à notre
vocabulaire notre façon de s'adresser
aux autres au sens civique
voilà un peu de un peu de un peu de
bonté de bienveillance de chaleur